hey I'd like to welcome everybody to
this episode of the Arthur C Clarke
Center for human imaginations into the
impossible podcast I am your fearful
host uh Brian Keating joining me today
is one of my favorite author science
journalists Sarah skulls hello Sarah
hi Brian thanks for having me
yeah it's great to have you uh um into
the impossible podcast today we'll be
discussing your brand new book which is
your second book I believe uh and it is
called there they are already here about
why there is this uh frequently reported
description of flying saucers and and
why that may be and what that tells us
about the state of the world and how
people perceive interesting phenomena
such as unidentified flying objects so
uh Sarah I have to say your last book
making contact was a was a biography of
Jill Tarter and and the realm of kind of
a investigative journalism so to speak
but also pursuing this ambitious goal of
perhaps hearing and listening to perhaps
extraterrestrial intelligence and now
you're writing a book you've written a
book a wonderful book about uh seeing
flying saucers unidentified flying
objects in various locations around the
world and my next question for you is
what is is next for you is it a book
about Yeti or Loch Ness Monster
I feel like other other writers kind of
have the Cryptids and
pretty well covered
um I'm actually I've actually been doing
some research into the history of
Doomsday cults lately um now that we're
in this strange state of the world so I
don't know if that will turn into
anything or not but I have a batch of
books to read about it so we'll see what
happens well maybe that'll bring you
down to San Diego where we've had our
fair share of Cults uh some
unfortunately successful in their
pursuit of their own personal doomsdays
but uh I can't I can't wait to learn
more about that project for you uh so I
wanted to talk begin the book a
discussion of um they are already here
and we'll have not only a uh you know a
screenshot from the book's cover and
some images that you've provided us but
also we'll have a giveaway for listeners
on the iTunes Store to the actual audio
version of the podcast uh we'll give
away a copy once the bookstores get
liberated from Lockdown we are currently
in covid lockdown
I want to talk
um about the book The process of writing
the book and of course you know
hopefully entice our listeners our
audience to go and pick up a copy but I
want to ask first after writing making
contact
um what impelled you to want to write
this book and sort of
setiadjacent in a sense so what um what
what impelled you to want to write uh
they are already here
yeah actually when I finished making
contact I didn't intend to write any
other books and definitely not any more
books about uh aliens or alien adjacent
things
um that was kind of unexpected but it
all started when there was a New York
Times story that came out in late 2017
that was all about this Pentagon
research program that supposedly had
done a bunch of work trying to figure
out what UFOs are or as the military
likes to call them UAP an identified
aerial phenomena because it sounds more
serious
um and I was very interested in this
story as someone who had done a bunch of
research on study and um had kind of
covered the the space industry for a
while and I just started setting out
trying to uh confirm or deny all the
things that were in this story about
about this UFO research program
um and in doing that anytime
um as you know as a scientist or a
journalist when you go out to research
something you meet a bunch of people
who've been researching it for much
longer than you um and who know a lot
more than you do and it was when I met
those people
um who had been really interested in
UFOs for years or decades that I
discovered that uh UFO people as I
sometimes call them are not just all you
know conspiracy theorists Kooks there's
a lot of very smart good researchers out
there who just happen to have this as
their subject and then I started to
think you know why and what place do
UFOs hold in our culture because they're
this really persistent phenomenon and um
that's too long for one article so I had
to go off and write a book
oh you are very renowned journalist and
in fact we met several years ago you did
a story about one of the research
projects I was involved with to look for
peculiar phenomena known as Cosmic
birefringence and twists and certain
properties of the light that comes from
the earliest times in the cosmos and
that kind of segues into you know my
first set of you know questions as a
professional astronomer you know does
observations including some conducted
with large radio telescopes such as the
ones behind me in my screen virtual
background from the very large array out
in Socorro New Mexico we use these
massive telescopes and you know
basically any night of the year for a
radio telescope is almost as good as a
perfectly pristine clear crisp night
that you describe in the book having
experienced the 2017 eclipse of the Sun
and then encountering a unidentified
flying object I want to first you know
kind of theme this conversation around
the very weighty and important issues
that you bring up in this book of
confirmation bias and sort of you know
the the notion that we sometimes see
what we want to see but I want to begin
with a question that some of my
astronomer friends want me to ask you
which is you know given that we have you
know thousands of telescopes radio
microwave and and optical telescopes
flying the skies looking for any shred
of evidence
um uh over the last you know 50 hundred
years where the seti kind of um not not
just seti but but the notion of
extraterrestrials perhaps visiting this
planet how come we tend not to see them
in from coming from professional
astronomers in your opinion
yeah well I think the the first and
probably easiest answer to that question
is that astronomers tend to be more
familiar with what they see in the sky
um if somebody who is looking at data
from a telescope all the time sees
something anomalous either trains to
um you know try try very hard to figure
out what it is and not just say that's a
crazy thing and I don't understand it
but to go out and try to understand it
and then also are familiar with things
like uh you know you get a lot of people
just casual observers who will see
things like Venus which can look very
strange in the sky and think that's a
UFO but an astronomer would think that
looks like it's in the part of the sky
where Venus is
um and uh in terms of you know
telescopes I think that that is a good
question why we have all of this hard
data um not just from astronomical
Observer stories but also from
space-based observatories that are doing
Earth observation that could
theoretically see
some sign of
alien presence up on Earth and why they
why they don't um as far as we know and
uh I think that's a problem for the the
UFO Community if we have all of these
sensors why we don't have any hard data
and what we have instead are just a
bunch of eyewitness reports and I think
especially physical scientists are
um rightly very skeptical of of
eyewitness reports
um and I know I know personally I mean
I'm not a scientist I'm a journalist but
when
um especially prior to this book if I
saw something I didn't understand in the
sky like it wouldn't have a deep effect
on me I don't think really in the way
that it does for a lot of people I would
just see it and think that's weird I
don't understand what that is but um
probably someone could and I think a lot
of people without scientific training
especially
um think then that if they don't
understand it then therefore it must be
not understandable which is just a
difference and a difference in thinking
yeah so one thing that we are you know
both uh connected to is being open to
evidence but not you know hopefully not
being prejudiced by the desire to
believe something for example and that's
Afflicted
um you know as I've discussed in the
past and in many different uh regimes
whether it be in science when we want to
make a big Discovery for different
reasons uh personal professional
um uh Prestige that that sometimes
influences decisions that uh in ways
that aren't intrinsically scientific and
you go through the book and you talk a
little bit about you know one of the
most foremost kind of uh popular culture
references to the um to the phenomena of
of UFOs and that is of course the
X-Files and the theme or sort of the
tagline of the of the X-Files on all
these posters is I want to believe and I
usually get asked this question as a
scientist you know what do I hope to see
and what do I want to come out of I
given project and it's a very delicate
question because on one hand you can't
help but you know have a desire you're
only Human After All and we're humans
doing science even despite the uh you
know kind of cliches to the contrary but
uh what do you make of this desire that
for some of these it's hard enough for
someone to be as a scientist to keep his
or her confirmation bias out of the uh
out of the the mixture but how do you
what do you make of it for people that
are you know maybe prone to believing in
in conspiracies whatever that means and
and or you know perhaps cover-ups by
more powerful agencies what is it about
the human brain that that really uh
seeks to
observe or discern these phenomena
yeah I think I mean anytime you go into
a topic and you already know what you
want to find which like like you said
afflicts all of us no matter how
objective we try to be that can't help
but affect your thinking and um you know
the scientific process has some built-in
checks and balances against that at
least at least in some places
um but if you're a person who let's say
you you want to believe in UFOs like uh
Mulder on the X-Files then when you do
see Venus on the the skyline
um or or something else
[Music]
um
and you're going in wanting to see
something strange then chances are you
you're more likely to interpret it as
something strange because that supports
this view that you already had and I
think probably most of us are prone to
that in some ways and that but then you
can stop yourself and say I just think
that because that's what I want to think
but that's I think that's kind of a
little bit against our our natural
nature so it takes an extra kind of
metacognitive
steps
um I think there's also this additional
element that uh
a lot of the uo anthropology ties who I
talked to pointed out which is
um that
you know movies and TV and books The
X-Files you know everything
um that's about UFOs or alien heads on
Earth has trained us from from the time
that we started consuming media to think
that when we see something weird in the
sky it must be an alien spaceship
because that was what was in
Independence Day and
um The X-Files and basically anything
else and if we didn't come into it with
that interpretation you know we
might think of it as something else like
maybe if we grew up in a culture where
we were uh where all the movies were
about weird atmospheric phenomena we'd
be like wow look at that weird
atmospheric phenomenon and it's just we
go we come into it with all these
cultural biases built in that it's hard
to even recognize as biases because
they're so they're the water that we
swim in
yeah that's uh one of the things that
that I noted I've been reading your book
and talking with friends and family
about it is that it's really kind of a
stealth psychology book
it's really written in a perspective
that um you really have to examine
yourself as John Muir you know one of
the foremost
um naturalists in history described you
know his voyage into nature as more
going you know going out as he went out
he went in and the way that he found
himself is really by looking uh by by
going out into the wild I'll get that
quote but we'll put it in the show notes
but the point is that
um that the book has has a real uh
wonderful quality about it this is uh
again we're talking about Sarah skulls
about her book they are already here uh
why people see saucers and this is uh
really highlighted in a way that
surprised me one you know I'm of course
familiar with standard sort of uh
perceptions of lay people and even
scientists that are kind of
anti-government and even
anti-authoritarian but what what
surprised me is that the general public
thinks of us you know we astronomers as
a sort of the man or you know this this
culture of authority and you describe
you know kind of these these government
installations that are really
astronomical facilities and I wonder if
you could take the listeners through
that uh that that Journey to the various
you know major telescope facilities you
yourself had worked at one in your
previous uh life and career and then
that in some part small part led to of
course making contact and writing um
writing the authoritative biography of
Jill Tarter my friend Joe Tarter
um so can you say something about why
why isn't if it surprised you that
people kind of perceive even astronomers
as part of uh perhaps a you know a
Kabbalah of maliciousness
yeah I think there is definitely a
certain subset of of people who do
whether it's like the far end of things
of you know Flat Earth Believers
thinking that astronomers are
manipulating data to show a circular
Earth and faking the orbits of things
from space or people who think that
there's somebody at Nasa manipulating
images of uh from you know the Mars
rovers to remove the alien so that we
don't see them and that is a theory that
exists and
um what I have found partly from yeah
like you mentioned I used to work at
Greenbank Observatory which is a radio
telescope in in West Virginia and I by
job there was uh interacting with the
public a lot and I was surprised to
learn when I worked there that lots of
people
um you know probably one on every other
tour thought that we had some secret
evidence of aliens that we just weren't
telling them about and a I was like they
definitely wouldn't tell me because I
would tell everyone
um and be like in general genres aren't
hiding things because the culture of
science is to you know produce Produce
open data and do things in public and
make things transparent
um but I think what I found from um
from working in green bank and visiting
various other spots including the one
that appears behind you right now it's a
very large array
um is that
um you know to a lot of people astronomy
is really uh opaque profession to use an
astronomical word like people might read
stories about
you know Cosmic discoveries but they
don't
um really understand exactly how it
happens or what it is these telescopes
are doing especially ones like radio
telescopes where they don't produce
traditional
um you know visual images uh visible
light images that you can see
um and so that's that's one thing so
when something is opaque people just
kind of put their own interpretation on
it sometimes and then there's also the
element that a lot of
scientific facilities have started their
lives as uh military facilities or with
some kind of military funding in their
passion now with the Internet it's not
hard for people to find that out and
then kind of springboard that into the
present and say Well they're still doing
secret government work and and things
like that and just to see all of these
invisible hands in the background kind
of moving the pieces and um yeah I don't
I don't think of this astronomers as the
men but um I can definitely understand
why some people might yeah well you know
another aspect that that comes through
um a little bit more in making contact
than than in they are already here it's
kind of this adversarial nature of
science in that you know there's nothing
more that I would like to do than to you
know make make a discovery but there's
you know second to that in many
scientists Minds is it's almost
disproving someone else's Discovery
because that's the real nature of
scientific confirmation is that it must
be confirmed it must be replicated in an
independent uh reproducible fashion
um you know we always refer to this you
know as a peer review Etc and despite
you know some of my colleagues have a
poster in their offices I have no peers
but but you know for most of us we
certainly have peers and superiors but
the question of you know if somebody
were to see something you know there'd
be nothing you know more more you know
kind of uh significant in an
astronomer's career than to actually
make a discovery and I wonder does the
UFO culture even recognize that that
that having you know peer review of the
equivalent of a peer review or some kind
of crowdsourcing of the of data or of
observations could benefit the credulity
that people have in Greater Society
elements of the people who are
interested in UFOs who would welcome
that kind of thing and there have been
different attempts to try to do that
like there's an organization called
mufons the mutual UFO Network that has
kind of tried to
standardized investigation and you know
produce reports they're not
peer-reviewed but they're trying to have
some kind of reproducible procedure
um but a hard thing about that and like
we were talking about earlier is that
lots of the data that exists right now
that people are trying to dig into is
first-person accounts which we all know
are not very reliable no matter who you
are
um like if I had an account you
shouldn't trust it
um probably and
um I think you know there there are
people do advocate for attempts to get
to get hard data and do peer review and
in uh but
the UFO culture in general is not as
open as scientists are like there's
there's one guy named Robert Bigelow who
has funded a number of UFO studies
um that we're supposed to collect this
hard data with you know sensors and
cameras and spreadsheets and and you
know software and scientific type things
um and that data for whatever reason I'm
not sure
um never became public and never got
published in a peer-reviewed journal and
so I think
um in a lot of cases that's probably
related to the I want to believe
phenomenon is that people are finding
data that doesn't align with their
hypothesis and when that happens
you don't want to publish it which this
happens to scientists sometimes too
um who don't publish their null results
or things like that but
um I think it's more prevalent in the
UFO community
yeah so
um speaking of Bigelow I want to kind of
address that particular elephant in the
room and kind of Wonder you know what is
it about uh Rich mostly men that are
seemed to be so drawn to this or a
prominent men versus women or did you is
it is it true I mean are there would you
say what would you say the gender you
know kind of breakdown is
yeah I would say excuse heavily uh meal
the general demographic
yeah
in contact of course you know one of the
lead
characters in the sense is Paul Allen of
Microsoft Fame the late Paul Allen who
passed away uh about a year or so ago
and and Paul funded you know this
massive project that was really the
culmination of Jill tarter's career at
The seti Institute and and you described
the trials and tribulations of that
wonderful facility but you know kind of
yet to live up to to the promise that it
could have had but I wonder what is it
about these you know billionaires that
make them so intrigued about about
investigation of you know potentially
Fringe or you know at least outside the
scientific mainstream in some cases for
UFOs uh in particular maybe less so for
seti I think we'll get to you know the
status of sevi in a little bit but um
what do you think appeals to them about
this uh about
um you know using their wealth to look
for things like UFOs I'm talking about
him and um uh the Blink 182 uh code
either uh Tom uh was it Tom yeah
um and that has ADD Astra
project can you maybe speculate on what
makes people uh devote so many so much
of the resources to this Pursuit
sure yeah I can absolutely uh with the
caveat that it's speculating and pop
psychology
um I think
in my mind what motivates people is this
similar to what you were just talking
about with Scientists where there's
nothing more appealing than making a
really big Discovery and that is a big
motivating factor in why people are
doing science or researching UFOs in the
first place because as fringes we think
of this topic as and it is fringe if
someone you know did find the Flying
Saucer and verify that it came from
outer space that would be a very large
that would be huge and I think that
um people with a lot of money who have
the resources to pursue something huge
and can also just risk losing all of
that money
um
are are willing to do it for the it's a
low probability High consequence event I
guess and when you get to a certain
place with your money and then also with
your reputation like people still
respected Paul Allen after he funded a
search for a broadcast from
extraterrestrials
um I'm not sure how much how much
respect people have for uh Tom Delong or
but you know Robert Bigelow is a
businessman who
um well actually his his company
recently shut down for a while due to
due to the pandemic but he had a module
attached to the space station the key to
the big NASA contractor taken seriously
um and yet ran like a paranormal
Research Institute and I think once you
get to a certain threshold you can kind
of do what you want and people will say
like that's a quirky guy but they'll
still take you seriously yeah I think
that is interesting you know also again
pure speculation psychological armchair
analysis is worth what you pay for it
but you know this Legacy of of wanting
you know so somebody said recently you
know once once people about Jeff Bezos
and
um you know once they get to be a
certain level of wealth they really just
want to live forever and in some sense
you know making a discovery like this
would be you know scientifically uh
scientific immortality if you will uh
some maybe that's a part of it as well
one um person who I've always been very
interested in is Michael Shermer and and
hopefully uh you guys will connect
together too and Michael of course
describes an alien abduction that
happened to him in his book uh as well
as this wonderful book called mistakes
were made but not by me by car Carol uh
tabbers I don't know if you've read that
book before yeah that's a really good
book it's it's about all sorts of
cognitive dissonance and how human
beings cannot tolerate being in a state
of this dissonance and the extraordinary
links that police officers go to justify
to themselves that the you know that the
perpetrator is guilty and and how you
know attorneys will do similar things
and um even in marriage or relationships
that people will have kind of blinders
on while they're in the you know
pre-nuptial uh you know kind of phase
and then they all of a sudden their eyes
are open and and the part I haven't
completed I'm almost uh three quarters
of the way done but but basically I
believe that there's a virtue in
teaching these kinds of dissonance and
and biases and guarding against them
um at a young age as well as possible
and I think you know Michael's Adventure
when he was abducted by aliens or he
believed that he was uh uh really led
him into a new career which is quite the
opposite 183 opposite to towards the
realm of uh debunking uh and being a
skeptic uh which he'll hopefully as I
said have you on his show
and you know we we've discussed this TNI
together not just this adversarial
nature that scientists have and you know
whether or not it's it's a good thing I
think you know all Fields all Fields
need sort of a beginning phase where
they uh sort of get get their start and
uh and to take it seriously I think
things like seti have been have been
going on now for 60 years actually I
think this is the 60th year of uh the
original uh papers that were uh produced
in the project osma and you talk a
little bit about that in this book did
you find you know kind of old friends
and recurring themes coming from making
contact in the making of they're already
here
foreign
yeah there's not so much overlap exactly
with the people researching study and
the people researching UFOs but of
course the people who are doing study
um get a lot of emails and random phone
calls from people who are interested in
UFOs and want
um a respected astronomer to be able to
explain that to them but um one one
overlap I did find was one that uh
articulated by a radio astronomer named
astronomer named Garrett for sure who
once um once was involved in study and
it's in its earlier years and then came
to see the motivation behind it as
almost religious like even if a steady
astronomers as
um you know I go into this without a
hypothesis I am trying to find out
whether there is uh the intelligent life
elsewhere and I'm just trying to figure
that out he pointed out that it it has
to be motivated by the hope that it's
out there
um and also
um a lot of the justification for doing
study is about
um
you know things like if we find the
civilization they've existed for a long
time therefore
they must be peaceful because they
haven't you know Adam bombed each other
to death or they've figured out how to
solve their own global warming and so it
kind of has this salvation thing going
on and I think both of those
um which said the astronomers would
probably argue with
um do have some amount of overlap with
with UFO
um believers who kind of look to the
skies first for something more powerful
um and they wouldn't call it a God but
it kind of plays that that role for them
and I think that's he called it the
Salvation School of study yeah that's
very interesting yeah I want to get into
that towards the end in a few minutes
when we talk a little bit about the you
know kind of personal
um motivation and and perhaps
Revelations that you've had in the
writing of this book throughout before
we get there we had an event earlier
this year at the Arthur C Clarke Center
for human imagination uh which we called
uh is ET already lurking in our own
Cosmic backyard
with uh scientists and uh and authors
both of them uh Jim Benford and Paul
Davies and Paul Davies wrote a book in
2010 so exactly 10 years ago called the
Eerie silence and in that case uh he
makes the in that book he makes a very
convincing case that um that the
likelihood that the extraterrestrials
could have really overcome some of these
great giant hurdles to their existence
to become not only as Jill Tarter often
points out it's not enough that you
create life you know slime mold on on
Enceladus is very fascinating and
important but it has no technological
capabilities on the other hand he
pointed out you know perhaps it could be
that there could already be here uh
priests you know emptying your title uh
that aliens could be here but in the
form of sort of a shadow biosphere and I
wonder did you consider you know not
just the saucer appearance I mean of of
certainly UFOs that's by nature but but
of aliens among us but not in the kind
of prosthetic forehead type variety that
we typically see Detective
yeah it's yeah I didn't include it
um in the research but I have looked
into the shadow biosphere
um idea that life uh either arose twice
here or uh you know came here
um
from somewhere else and still exists and
I think that's I think that's an
intriguing possibility and I think
there's and there's the very smart
people who have written about
um ways to look for life as you don't
already know it and that seems to be the
problem with fighting the like a shadow
of biosphere here on Earth is uh how do
you how do you look for something when
you don't know what it is and how do you
differentiate it from this life and from
not life and it's it's an intriguing
it's an intriguing topic and um but in
in the research for they are already
here the form I most encountered it uh
ads was more likely there are reptilians
in Congress kind of
um form which is different from my
shadow of biosphere
uh so I'd like to conclude uh this a
wonderful discussion by asking questions
that are tangentially related to the
topic we were just discussing at least
at first and that has to do with with
reading and books and how you know in my
mind uh second only to DNA which you
know perhaps some alien microbe might
have in a slightly different form than
than we experience here on Earth but you
know what do books mean to you this is
your second book which is a heroic
accomplishment uh by uh by anyone's
standards uh but I I wonder you know
what do books mean to you and in the
case of you know the future Legacy that
a book can provide uh I always like to
ask my author guests if you would rather
prefer that you have uh a hundred
readers one year from now or one reader
a hundred years from now
hmm that is a hard question
[Music]
um
let's see
I think I think I would prefer
at least for this most recent work a
hundred readers now because I feel like
um not just not just for sales purposes
but I feel like this I undertook this
book based on something that happened
just a few years ago and it's kind of
reflecting on
um where we are now as a society and how
UFO belief Rises and falls with with
what's happening culturally and I feel
like maybe especially while we're all
isolated than our own houses in a in a
kind of moment of fear and uncertainty
which is something I talk a lot about in
the book that maybe this would have some
resonance Beyond just UFO people
um but I think uh for the book about
Jill Charter I might prefer one reader a
hundred years from now because when I
was when I was working on that book I
thought a lot about what what if study
succeeds someday and
um we find something and someone wants
to look back on what the Endeavor was
like in its early years and the people
who started it and like I can create
something now that someone in the future
could have as a as a present record
while all of the players are you know
alive and still still doing things
to us now
um but to me books um you know I read a
ton starting very early I was obsessed
with books
um I would go on card tips with my
family and my mom would always be
telling me to look out the window at the
nice things that the world that they
were showing me because I always had my
nose buried in a book
um but I think then and now
um you know is a way
uh to to go places that you can't go
um which is pretty cool right now and
um also a way to get uh different
perspectives on things you know there's
some studies about fiction reading and
empathy and how people who read fiction
especially have more empathy because
you're just forced to think about the
minds of other of other characters and
um yeah so that's that is I think what I
Look to them for oh great and speaking
of those readers now my next of the
second of the five questions that I like
to ask authors is of those readers those
hundred thousand readers that you're uh
hopefully gonna get thanks to this
podcast and and uh you know how how
we're going to advertise them on the
surface of the Moon uh for those hundred
readers thousand readers uh however many
you get of those who which sort of would
you prefer as your target audience
people that are skeptical about this
phenomenon or people that are you know
sort of are already down and they they
sort of already are predisposed to the
notion that UFOs exist
I think
I think prefer the people who are
predisposed to thinking UFOs exist
because I think it's always
useful to be able to
see from the outside something that
you're a part of and see how somebody
else views it and because I think UFOs
you know whatever they are to people no
matter what they think of them the
seeing of them is a human phenomenon and
when you're part of a part of like a
culture it's hard it's hard to see
it's it's flaws and it's good parts and
I don't know I think it's useful to have
a few from the outside
and somebody you know continuing on that
on that theme
um one question I like to ask especially
for people that are astronomically
inclined uh is a is a quote that I uh
read included in my book uh I saw on
kirkegaard who said that life can only
be understood backwards but must be
lived forwards I think that's just kind
of a you know it typifies astronomy
we're always looking back into space and
and seeing things as they were in the
past so I'm wondering if you could look
back uh into your past and and the book
is is very uh it's remarkable to me
because it's also very personal it talks
about you as a person and now that you
you know established your your credit
your credentials uh throughout your many
uh articles and and your previous book
now I think you know you're giving the
public your audience some more insight
into who you are so I'm curious as to
you know what do you think you would
look back and tell your 20 year old self
uh uh that it might seem possible at the
time but but looking forward it will
work out and and that kind of goes along
with the theme of this podcast into the
impossible is Sir Arthur C Clarke's
Second Law uh first being any
sufficiently advanced societies
indistinguishable from Magic and the
second one is the only way to find out
what is possible is to go a little bit
and out of your comfort zone into the
impossible so if you could tell 20 year
old Sarah uh the skulls a little bit of
advice what would that be
hmm yeah I mean I guess I think related
to the the the parts of my past that are
in the book when I was when I was 20
years old I was recently
um out of uh I had grown up a very
devout religious person my family was
Mormon than I had recently left at that
point I was
um you know skeptical and kind of I
don't know I can't think of a word other
than the meaning of of other people's
beliefs just because I found any kind of
belief so like anathema to this uh newly
very very skeptical very atheist point
at which I found myself and and kind of
a book like this where I'm
examining other people's beliefs it
forces you to you know give them
respect and try to understand them and
not just be like well
um I was Mormon and I'm not so I know
you and so I think I think I would tell
myself like just um you know you don't
you don't know everything and maybe take
a little more time to understand other
people which is probably something most
20 year olds could hear more often but
me especially I think that's right yeah
you describe your encounters at Area 51
last summer as you know kind of being
the Elder States woman in the group and
uh it's kind of delightful to hear the
journey that you go on and the Candor
that you exhibit in the book I always
like that
people are are honest about their own
and really portray you know you're not a
scientist as you said but you write a
lot about scientific topics and
um and I think you know to to show that
we are you know we none uh non
non-scientists shown on scientists that
we are human right
and a wonderful wonderful service that
you uh continue to provide the last
question is about
um curiosity and Imagination here at the
Arthur C Clarke Center for human
imagination I'm always uh you know
curious what my guests have to say about
their particular skill set and maybe
it's a set of skills you're a public
speaker you do journalism you do
scientific research into your subjects
at least you know kind of the large
large-scale game
um but what you do can it be taught can
you actually communicate teach is it
part partially uh you know born into who
you are and your life experiences and so
maybe it won't be able to be taught what
are your thoughts about the
transmutability of your of your values
and of your of your skill set
hmm I mean I think it is probably true
that people are born and then ingrained
through nurture with different levels of
um curiosity and engagement with the
world and with the people in it which I
I know that
um I mean as a journalist people people
think of you as mostly being a writer
but mostly my job is actually
talking to people not writing about them
that's the and and doing research and I
think that you can teach that in the
same way that you can teach yourself to
be aware of your own cognitive biases I
think you can teach yourself to be
curious about people and curious about
their stories and curious about how
that's all interacting with the world
around you and I think
um I mean especially even looking for
stories when I first started doing
journalism I think I saw it you know
that how will I ever find enough stories
and then as as soon as you
everything you encounter as an open
question that you can go investigate
then that's the way you start to see the
whole world and so um I think if you
just take a step and uh take a step back
and notice what your mind kind of maybe
wanders about for one second and then
instead of wondering about it for one
second just like dwell on it a little a
little more and talk to people about it
and I think I think that's transmutable
wonderful thank you so much all right
the last question is really the part of
the plug Zone not the Twilight Zone but
the plug Zone
um so where can people connect to you
online uh social media Etc
sure uh on Twitter I am full Sarah
s-c-o-l-e-s-s-a-r-a-h
um and I have a website where I put up
all of my articles which is
www.seraschools.com and you can find
information about the book there too
great and uh anything you want to say
about future project whether it's
writing or a book or Journal articles
hmm that's a good question and actually
uh let's see
it's uh it's mostly an open question
right now what comes next I have all
those books that I mentioned behind me
about
um
millennialist doomsday cult so that's uh
that's all TBD that people can keep an
eye out for whatever yeah
thank you so much it's been a real treat
I wish you the greatest success with the
book and I hope that you'll keep in
touch
yes definitely and thanks for having me
[Music]
is it will be absolutely fantastic
foreign
[Music]